yo yo this is quick today quick stream
guys quick stream hmm
wait for all I should go at least put it
on on Twitter yeah well we'll do it with
the Subaru harness is live
NIC is alive on the site right now no
wait what oh yo yo we live we live
Subaru varnas going live wait hang on I
got to find our Channel I got to find
our channel I'm on Twitter what's up we
got an announcement for everybody here
in a minute in a minute YouTube calm
he's alive
hey come on there's a lot no oh just
push it to the UH
oh no pushes website yeah yeah
alright alright alright alright alright
alright
when's the test jumper coming oh no test
Jarek but if you want to see the new one
logger I could show you that check it
out
I wrote this beautiful UI myself this is
like engaged it's like Explorer but fast
all right I know we are we good
live chat welcome to live chat oh yeah
you think July go again
I worked I worked hard on this UI that's
the speed of the car so then like you
can see this is like you I you know yo
yo yo
alright hello world it's a short
announcement today the short
announcement think like too short
I blocked Twitter to my Etsy host file
because otherwise I just go on Twitter
all that how am i doing today we're
doing good today
what are we good today all right I don't
really know there's not too much to say
it'll live streams this is gonna be mad
short but um so this is uh this is open
pilot here
if you go down to supported cars we
already support the Subaru Crosstrek and
Impreza um we also have a pull request
which means we're gonna get support
pretty soon for the Subaru Legacy and
the Subaru Outback no promises on those
but if you have a cross trecorum present
today and you buy we're gonna refresh
this web page in a little bit but first
we're gonna go for a walk
these are Subaru harnesses they attach
to your black panda in your harness so
this is just the standard , 28 pin
connector and that's your pass through
four Subaru neither of these connectors
is 3d printed they're both real
connectors why nobody's gonna come to
the stream today we didn't announce it
we didn't plan anything but Subaru do
you see what this says it says ready to
ship so that's just because it's ready
to ship do you have any comments on the
on the Subaru harness oh oh there's all
secrets Oh secrets Wow wow there's so
much so many leaks in here no no nope we
can't have any leaks
does anyone does anyone have any
comments on the Subaru harness eyesight
required yeah it should work with all
cars with eyesight all right oh no I'm
not you they can't see your screen don't
worry Wow wow this is this is this is
leaked Centralia wow there's so many
leaks going on in there's leaks on this
ticket what is that thick you know it's
I just say me leak is there any leaves
here we're leaks wrench leaks
all right no that's it for leaks let's
we'll just wait till it goes live right
now but with the Subaru horn
Subaru is it live yet it's not live yet
but just so you know we make the
development vehicle this is like that
stream when Elon announced the model y
and nobody really cared it's like that
but we're announcing the Subaru harness
let me go get a Subaru harness so I can
hold it up every time I say Subaru
harness I can't show you oh
leaks no no we're walking down here so
so nobody can see any leaks no leaks no
leaks no leaks no we will show you the
datacenter you know I love showing off
the datacenter wow it's beautiful it's
so big we did can't leak to you the door
code well they're gonna be analyzing
those leaks for a long time yeah oh you
want Sabrina farm we gotta go look at
printer farm this is a Subaru harness
prynt mom civic
Oh Oh is those FCA not launched yet but
that's an FCA connector walk so don't
worry you didn't miss anything we're
just launching the Subaru harness today
we have a black band around our harness
thingy that I can plug it into so this
will be mounted inside your shoe root
it's the same one that goes in the Civic
in the Toyota Subaru harness if you by
Subaru harness for $400 yeah one only
half only half the FCA is this Ally
yeah look at that look at how satisfying
this Joe anything to say about the
Subaru harness yeah with this is what
we're showing on everything seen this oh
look at that Wow it's like this is nice
nice plastic huh yeah are these the real
we didn't print these no no we don't
plug it in like that when you get it it
intercepts your Subaru it should work
with all new Subarus with eyesight I
believe and you see this it passes
through five of the wires the Subaru
harness is that do we have the old
Subaru harnesses around to show them now
it was bad it was bad we sold three of
them so I'm hoping Gilly I'm
acknowledging your message by a harness
for your subaru today when it's kama
doing an IPO that's a forward-looking
statement I'm not allowed to say that no
you can hack your own Subaru with a
Subaru harness buy it today prevent low
speed lockout oh I'm excited about the
smart TSU intercept you're gonna sell
them when is it going live all right why
don't we go live to our sales team and
we ask when they're going live
Subaru harness Cohen life super harness
is almost like we got we got 81 people
here they're very excited for Subaru
harness it's gonna be a 20-minute yeah
hey you know do you have any comments on
the Subaru harness good any comments on
the Subaru harness it's finally time
whoa whoa whoa no torque interceptors
Petar see how thank you for buying one
you make it worth it for us you're just
gonna drop down I think we're adding
reading uh just crosstrack and uh yeah
cool and that sorry is it on the leg
harness nice nice
Subaru now officially supported by comma
a we're doing FCA soon - so the harness
you know harness technology Oh exclusive
leagues for come a prime subscribers ok
everybody else cover your ears wait wait
we actually have an exclusive league for
come over I'm subscribers we actually
have
can we easily show them take picked they
ask for leaks for common prime
subscribers yeah yo check this out look
at the pictures it's taking pictures
right now alright so this is the me it's
me guys look we did it yeah so that's an
exclusive that's gonna be a comma prime
exclusive feature you're gonna be able
to take a picture with your car make
sure to sign up for comma prime before
we rate the prices um yeah yeah gamma
prime prime is incredible
do you intentionally stream on data to
minimize leaks no not streaming a data
eric moraga whoa finally something cool
um baa what what we'll celebrate with it
when the Subaru harness goes live I
don't know what that is
look a skateboard ssh become a prime now
with camera what youtube showed you an
ad what am i getting the revenue for
that i don't think so
the leak I think we cover like 50
something cars yeah yeah so just so if
you already bought a harness for some
reason um you'll be able to buy just
this table for 50 bucks but if you buy a
harness it includes the harness it
includes the common power v2 it includes
the black Panda
yeah we're by Google man no you know
what we'll thought by like one of those
car companies one of those American car
companies when they don't get bailed out
will bottle that's right and we'll fire
everybody and replace him with robots
so I'm sayin and you robot any roadmap
for flex right cars no you are out of
luck buy a cheaper car bro trade in your
car you know when you go to a dealership
you can trade in a car and they'll
actually give you money if the
tradin value of that car is higher the
new car don't buy GM um if I buy Faraday
future yeah bloated [ __ ]
I'm fingerprinting to point out yeah
we're working on it we're working on it
what was the unlocker stuff it was just
something that's what I've been working
on this week it's actually already live
if you go and open pilot tools and you
look in Nui how's the sound division
doing sound divisions killing it we love
the new sound clarity uh-oh I don't know
about that one oh yeah I'm sorry you
bought a weird car if you trade it in
your car you'd ask for money well I
don't know how to uh leaks alright let's
see this is my new one logger Dearing
controls
oh and you but they're they're $50 why
, power v2 includes the correct wire for
your Subaru USBC cable Ethernet cable
and that's what your yun looks like
mounted well these aren't leaks this
won't live a while ago you want to see
leaks these are the websites that I
block um is it lagging is the quality
bad oh wow oh it's real potato quality
that's bad ass low-quality crap can we
increase the quality
wow that's I don't know man that's bad
but ya know Subarus gonna go live any
minute now what we'll just sit here
we'll just sit here I'll wait with you
guys while Subaru goes live no I'm on my
Wi-Fi I don't I don't get it
Oh yo you know what I got in the mail
today but I don't have it
my air Potts air pod Pro that was no
leaks on the board this checking I'm
paranoid about leaks Oh Oh guys guys
it's live it's live right now you can
pick your Subaru Crosstrek
or your stupor or impress out and you
can add to cart' you know what this
guy's a known hater you know what
happens to known haters hide user on
this channel perfect uh-oh the accordi
PS oh you want to show me a core DPS
[Music]
yeah so so Subaru right they're only
three ninety-nine that's a good price
you're good bro I like you I'll give you
a harness for 399 super easy just buy it
right now I'm just gonna check quickly
to see if anybody's buying it you know
what if we've sold if we sell at least
if we sell three of them in the next two
minutes we're gonna show you guys the
accordi PS but if we don't sell three of
them we're not showing your decoy DPS
anyone buy any yet come on bye bye bye
no one's bought any yet if our harness
is a fantastic product thank you where's
nougat cosmos League's leaks are let's
go and just go ahead and see what the
live live leaking situation is Subaru
people yeah come on you know you want to
see the accordi PS you got it you got a
bi no super people buy anything
Oh Subaru
oh so quick all the leaks got covered up
the leaks are gone oh you didn't get any
leaks people might be buying a Subaru um
if you're going out and buying a Subaru
may I recommend it to Leo to corolla but
if you're in the situation where you
already have a Subaru come on we got we
got we got to sell a few of these zero
sold so far but only 90 viewers I know I
know I know because we didn't do any
real press for this because it's like
you know it's low-quality crap you got
an exclusive , prime leak yeah take
picture bros mah by subaru but also
another thing if you don't have a
harness for your car you should get a
harness even if you don't have a Subaru
um Oh Bugsy I mean if yours has the same
pin outs as ours and you're using the
same harness absolutely keep selling
them what we're just we're not making a
lot of money on these cables that's why
they've been debunked glad you enjoyed
the medium article 2020 Corolla hybrid I
think we fixed that oh sorry we fixed
that in the secret good version of open
pilot down specs it's up what if you buy
a hundred two weeks from now if you
actually want to buy we have we have
bulk discounts um we've gotten a few
orders in the last couple weeks of ten
Yuans and we offer decent discounts to
buying ten so you can just reach out to
Boyd a comment I have you're serious
about buying in large quantities if
you're buying a hundred will give you a
phenomenal price yeah
oh yes zero six six I think I think let
me just double check but I think zero
six six is gonna support the the Corolla
hybrid yes all right all right you want
to see some more leaks I'll show you
some more leaks leaks
thanks wok so alright guys I'm glad to
have you all here with me but
unfortunately I don't think anyone uh
yep no bleep on and he's super I really
does anyone actually have a sugru or is
it just trolls oh crap that was a leak
oh we leaked that oh yeah yeah yeah Jay
Young has done a great job we're super
happy no trucks no how many versions
before zero seven well that's that so
that's too much of a leak no I think the
issue is that nobody actually has a
Subaru if you buy if you buy your stuff
today will I promise we'll support your
uh your Corolla hybrid by the time
against their defenses Liam nope like I
know some like I know some like like
people who have Subarus but they're like
Subarus from 1992 I don't know anybody
who buys a new burro
so I'm just just okay so we sold exactly
zero Subaru harnesses so guess why uh
you don't get you don't get to see the
uh yeah if you buy me a Subaru exactly
exactly
oh you have a nineteen Forester all
right let's do point that soon I think I
think of all the cars have it now you
don't have a neon yet yo okay I'll show
you guys I'll show you get yeah yeah
we're working on the outback we got we
gotta merge that I know I know
ten sales ten sales will be great you
mean ten young sales that'd be
phenomenal who'd be so happy with Kenny
on sales but I did leak how much money
we made this but we're rich boys were
rich Subarus torque seems pretty good
yes superoes are nice cars if you get
over the fact of our sewers but I don't
mean to discourage anybody with the
Subaru if you guys were if you guys were
all you know buying up this harness
really fast I'd be like man you guys are
all great I love Subaru people but when
nobody buys anything well you know how
to
I had a lot of how am I supposed to feel
um but I believe in you Subaru people
know that maybe you take your time to
make to make a decision
I'm not running ads I don't know if
there are ads if you buy a Subaru
harness right now will I make the Kia
all the handout one yeah yeah we're
working on that you a key IKEA key and I
are the same car right supers Castle
down now when I cancel at it anymore
okay we know we're doing we're doing the
q1 as well all right what other what
other car ports we want buy a Subaru one
right now and what we'll do the key
light will do it even if you don't buy a
Subaru harness but somebody's coming
principal refresher on the sales page
nope nope nobody nobody buys subaru
harnesses but if you're excited about
that , prime leak make sure to buy ,
prime go in your comment app is very
convenient and easy it could somebody
please buy us a new harness great wall
SUVs I don't know about that
nope we're just gonna we're just gonna
leave this stream where absolutely uh
you know last time we did the super
harness we sold three how many people
have a Subaru with an open pilot I can't
believe nobody bought them either
is the website broken Subaru harnesses
are a great deal
they're only 399 for your Subaru I mean
it makes your Subaru like like way
better
you know those makes you forget you have
a Subaru oh because you already all have
harnesses okay uh I think we can check
the stats
bring that up one time fingerprinting
vehicles relative let's say 30
oh you can't process payments what I'm
sure to work um almost you guys are
early adopters already bought all right
cool I don't we're not going 30 months
ago although 30 days ago I will update
let's see ooo we see a super here
here we go so our most popular car of
course is the toyota prius followed by
nun civics see RVs vaults civics
Corollas Accords Corollas rap fours
Accords rap fours
Honda's Odysseys Camrys rap force
Accords CRV is Camrys we hyundai oh oh
there we go
15 Subaru Impreza limited
there we go that's Subaru I think the
wall upstream cars yeah Wow 3 likes on
the 3 likes on the on the Subaru and one
of them's our car to help your parents
have a Subaru
I add more add more yeah yeah yeah what
Willie had more but this isn't
encouraging this isn't encouraging for
Subarus who said if I acknowledged them
they were gonna buy one can you get a
tutorial yeah if you search for open
pilot carport
and do a media post I did all these
leaks for you I won't be pretty bought a
harness all right all right all right
well you can't process payment I don't
know there's no new hardware you guys
got the new hardware the new hardware
already came out it's called the car
harness go check it out it's not pin
post on Twitter
not the wait till 2020 on new we all
know I don't know about that
yo if you guys want to see how many lay
echoes we have to continue making eons
Gilly come on it cold quick let's if
this dream gets to the 30 minute mark
and not even a single sugru harnason
soul I'm just gonna I'm gonna sit at my
desk and I'm gonna go get ice cream
actually that's what I'm gonna do and
you know what if one is salt I'm gonna
go get ice cream too but the difference
is that if one gets sold it's gonna be
celebration ice cream and if none gets
old it's gonna be feel better ice cream
guys Legos are the future top thing as
far as no toppings now we're not getting
toppings are going to a shukshin scoop
no no no Shelton straw that's act okay
okay okay at least we got seven likes on
the on the Subaru harness no no no no
we're gonna eat a moderate amount of ice
cream we're gonna eat in moderation Wow
well you know what I was thinking about
doing a stream for the FCI harness but
now there's no FCI harness stream and
you know why the FCA people the FCA
people can blame the Subaru people for
not buying any Oh nonono shippers /
shippers / you know why shippers / guys
because they're no longer giving us any
free cloud money when they gave us lots
of free cloud money we ran chipper and
then the free cloud money runs out and
then the shipper runs out cuz shipper
didn't you know make any money but
apparently Subaru harnesses don't make
any money either oh no oh yeah you know
about that is that Arduino Uno that's
what I'm talking about
yeah I don't know I don't feel like
streaming on Twitch anymore this is the
stream that you get if you want if you
want to stream this is the stream you
get 30 more seconds of stream come on
come on buy a super
check them Apple watch
quick Gilly get in I'm just gonna show
you guys the accordi PS I'm gonna show
you more great leaks but nope nobody won
all right we'll see all you later thank
you for joining me for the stream have a
nice evening and today we learned the
truth that there are no people out there
who actually own a Subaru just people
who say that they do bye bye